if you've ever tried making a bap in r
you might be overwhelmed by the sheer
number of packages that exist
these packages may look completely
different and take in differently shaped
data so it can be pretty confusing to
figure out which one to use
today i want to show you how to quickly
and reliably make beautiful maps in r
just like these with the plotly package
if you see my other videos you might
remember i created one on interactive
graphs with plotly it's a fantastic
package that's well maintained and can
produce impressive visualizations just
out of the box
so let's get started the first map we're
going to be making is this interactive
choropleth map of the us
we've got different u.s states colored
by different minimum wages
and we have this slider at the bottom
that allows us to change the year our
first step is going to be loading in our
packages
plotly of course is going to help us
build out these interactive maps dplyr
is going to help us with some data
cleaning and data wrangling and the
reader library for reading in our csv
files
now let's load in our data i'm using
this data set i found online of minimum
wages by states
by year but we're only going to be
looking at a few of these columns so
here i'm reading in my data set
and i'll go ahead and run this just so
we can take a look we've got year state
and wage
but we actually need to do one more
thing to this data frame the way the
choropleth maps and plotly work for
u.s states when you're telling plotley
that you want to color a certain state
like alabama you actually need to use
the state abbreviation the two-letter
abbreviation
so i actually have to go and find a
different data set online with just
states and their abbreviations just so i
could join the two tables together
so let me do that really quick we'll
read in our csv file called states and
we'll include an inner join with our
minimum wage data frame
and states and instead of selecting the
state
name we're actually just going to select
the state code
and we can run all of this so now we've
got our year
our state code and our wage so let's
move on to step two which is actually
making our graph
we're first going to start by creating a
new variable called min wage graph
and we're going to call the plot geo
function this is part of the plotly
library
we need to specify our data so that's
going to be min wage df
we also need to specify a location mode
in this case we're looking at u.s states
so we'll put in usa states and
essentially by doing this that'll tell
plotly that
our geographic data is going to be using
those state codes and in order to get
that slider at the bottom with all the
different years
we need to specify the frame by the year
column
and just note that anytime you're
calling one of these columns in the
plotly functions you have to put in the
tilde for it
so we're done with the plot geo function
we're going to pipe this into add trace
which is just adding this trace layer
onto our graph
we're going to specify the actual states
so the variable is locations
and the column name is code which again
has our two letter state codes
we also need to specify a z and a color
and
in this case it's going to be our wage
because that's how we want the states to
be colored by the different wages
and once we've done that we can go ahead
and run this and now output our min wage
graph
and you see we get this map of the world
we've got our slider on the bottom
and because it's plotly we can zoom in
and of course hover over our data points
to see
more granular data but this graph is far
from complete so let's make a few
changes
we first want to make sure that we're
showing just the us and not the whole
world
so this is pretty easy we just need to
add another layer onto our plotly
map this one is going to be called
layout and we're going to set the geo
variable
to a list and the list is going to have
a variable called
scope which is set to usa and i know
this is a little confusing
but bear with me we can run all of that
again and now we just have the us
there are actually different types of
scopes and different projections that
i'd recommend you look at in the
documentation but you can get some
really cool looking graphs in plotly the
next thing we want to do is
mess with the actual colors that our map
is you'll notice that if we change the
frame
the scale of the wages actually changes
too so it starts with the max at 2
and by 2017 we're at about 11.
in order to fix that we just need to set
a min and max value for our wage
that'll be reflected in this legend over
here so in our add trace
we can set a z min as zero and a z max
instead of manually specifying it i'm
going to call the max function and we
want the highest value
in this wage column so that'll just be
min wage
df wage i also want to get away from the
default color palette so
i'm going to set our color scale down
here to the electric color palette
we'll run all this again now you can see
the legend has the wage from zero all
the way to the max and our color palette
is a bit different
the other thing i noticed was that the
hover data isn't super informative
when i hover over each of these dates i
want it to show me the state name
and the dollar value but with an actual
dollar sign so what i'm actually going
to do first is create a new column
as part of our min wage data frame so
i'll call the mutate command from d
plier and i'll make our variable name
called hover i'll use
paste 0 so i can concatenate some
variables together and i want to
concatenate the state name
so i'm actually going to call state but
i need to make sure i specify it up here
first
and then a new line and then the dollar
sign
and then our wage variable and i'll run
all of this and just show you what our
data frame looks like now
so now our hover variable has alabama
and then a new line character that you
can actually see and then
the wage now we just need to get that
column to appear when we hover over
these data points
in order to do that we just go back to
our add trace we pass in another
argument called
text and this is going to be again a
column which is hover
we can go ahead and run that now we get
zero montana zero dollars and mt so we
still have too much data being shown
we just need to make sure that the hover
info variable is only showing
our text that's specified here and this
is kind of a weird way to do it to have
to specify
the text and hover info but i haven't
found a better way to do it so let me
know if you do
if we run all this now when we hover
over our states we only see
the relevant data and again as we cycle
through the frames this data will update
and change the labels so functionally
i'm pretty happy with this graph but i
still think that there are some
aesthetic changes i want to make
i want to change up the font of the
graph and also the style of the labels
and i want to get rid of this toolbar at
the top and maybe even add a title so
let's start with the font and the labels
we can change the font by going back
down to our layout function
and passing in the font the family i'm
going to use
is dm sans and this is just a font
that's installed on my computer
if you want to see all the fonts you can
use all you need to do is called
library extra font and of course install
it if you don't have it and then you can
go ahead and call
the fonts command and this will show you
any of the fonts that you can use
so this will change the fonts of the
graph but i also want to change the
label style
so i'm actually going to make some
variables up here the first is going to
be called
font style and again we're going to
specify our family as dm
sans just so it matches the rest of our
graph we're gonna make the size 15 and
the color of the label is going to be
black we're also going to make a label
variable where the background color
is going to be this hex value the border
color
is going to be transparent the font is
going to be the font style that we just
created up there we can run all of this
and now just to make sure that our
plotly graph is using this information
we need to add another layer called
style where our hover label is equal to
this label variable that we specified up
here and if we run all of this to
refresh our graph
now you can tell it's subtle but the
font has changed and if i hover over
it's now
this white box with no border and our dm
sans font
so let's also get rid of this toolbar up
here this is also pretty easy we just
need to add a config layer and set
display
mode bar to false and if we run that we
can see that it doesn't appear when i
hover over
let's add in a title and that'll just be
in our layout with the title variable
we'll call this minimum wage in the us
this is from the year 1968 to
2017 so i'll just specify that and
lastly
wage right now these numbers might not
be very obvious so let's just add a
dollar sign before them and we can do
this with the help of another layer
called color bar
where we set a tick prefix to
the dollar so let's run all this just to
see where our graph is
and it looks pretty good to me we've got
our legend updated
the labels look good title looks good
and our visualization is actually pretty
insightful
so let's move on to our next example
this one is going to be a scatter plot
on top of a map so we're plotting
longitude and latitude data as opposed
to state or country data and unlike
before we're not going to use any of the
interactive capabilities that plowly has
we're just focused on building a very
basic scatter map so we'll start by
reading in our data and just selecting
some of the columns so i can give you
guys a good view of what this looks like
so we've got about 88 000 rows of data
so a lot of data points with a longitude
a latitude
a day time and shape and i don't think
we'll be using these two columns since
we're only plotting the longitude and
latitude but just to give some more
context
and again we'll create our ufos graph
we'll call that plot
geo function with our data frame and now
we
specify a latitude and longitude with
the lat and long
variables so our latitude is our
latitude column
and our longitude is our longitude
column and again
these are just going to be the column
names that are in your data frame over
here now if i run this because there are
80 000 points
then plotly wants to give me an
interactive graph it's actually going to
take
a long time and make my computer slow so
i'm first going to build my graph just
based on a thousand data points and then
when it looks good i'll build out the
whole thing using all the data so i'll
just pass in
sample n to grab a random sample of a
thousand rows from this data frame
and we can output the graph as well so
let's run all that and we get a similar
map like we had last time where by
default it zoomed out to show the whole
world and just like before we're going
to make a lot more visual changes to
this
so the first thing is going to be making
the scope just the us before we just
specified
geo equals list scope usa but the geo
variable actually can take in a lot of
different arguments to
change the different colors of land
masses and borders so we're going to
create a separate variable
called geoproperties that's going to be
equal to a list and again the scope is
going to be usa
i was also talking about how there are
different types of projections and just
to show you what that's like
we can specify a projection type i'll
use albers usa
i'm going to set show land to true show
subunits to false so in this case
it won't show state outlines land color
is going to be
gray 10 which is like a dark gray show
lakes
is true and we're going to make the
lakes white and then just like before we
need to call
the layout layer with geo is now going
to be geo properties
and let's run all this just to take a
look so we've got just the us now with
these blue dots plotted but there are a
couple other changes we need to make
i want to make these blue dots a bit
smaller make them a different color
and obviously get all 88 000 of them
instead of just the 1000 i also need to
make sure that before plotting all those
88 000 i need to disable this hover
because
plotly will lag a ton and i might also
just remove this toolbar again
just to make this look a bit more
cleaner so we'll start by customizing
these little dots
and that's not too difficult we just
need to pass in another variable called
marker that takes a list the size of
each point i'm going to do
is 2 which is pretty small and will look
good with a lot of data points i'm going
to make the color
almost a light yellow and i'm also going
to set the opacity to
0.25 just so we get the cool effect
where we can see different clusters
based on a lot of data points being
plotted there right now it's a little
tough to see
because the data points overlap each
other to get rid of the hover info
we actually add another layer called add
markers here we're explicitly specifying
them but by default they're already
plotted we can specify them just to
put in more properties so we'll say our
hover info is none and to get rid of the
toolbar up here we just need to copy
this display mode bar equals false
and i know that there are a lot of
different layers a lot of different
variables that i'm just randomly seem to
be passing in
and that is kind of the case you do have
to go into the documentation to figure
out exactly what you want to do but once
you have a decent map that you think
looks well you can typically reuse a lot
of those properties and layers each time
so i think it's worth learning some of
these different useful layers that
plotly has
so before we run all this let's just get
rid of our sample n
so we're plotting all the data and we
can run it if i open it up in my browser
it looks a bit better
you can see because of that opacity that
we set we can see those clusters of
where these big ufo sightings are and i
think this is a pretty cool
visualization so obviously these two
examples i did aren't
a very comprehensive view of all of
plotly's features and again i'd
recommend taking a look at the
documentation to really fine-tune
your plots the way you want them to look
but i'm hoping that i could show you how
you could quickly make
some pretty good looking plots and if
you found this video helpful in any way
i definitely recommend checking out
these other videos
right here